So when I was in high school,
I grew up in Canada in the Toronto
area specifically in the Milton area.
And there really wasn't a lot of money
to be had when I was in high school.
Poor kids running around farm country.
And I had a friend who had a truck,
and one day he turned to me and
said, hey you're smart.
Why don't you figure out a way
that we could make some money.
And I was just like okay, so
as he would drive me to and
from school I kept looking out the
window as you do when you're driving and
I would see farm equipment everywhere.
Old farm equipment rooting in
fields rusted, dilapidated etc.
One day, we were in the town and we
passed by building that had a huge sign
over it that said,
we buy your scrap metal.
Research revealed that this was
a recycling plant and then it struck me.
Hey, my friend's got a truck.
There's all this old farm
equipment rotting in fields that's
obviously not wanted.
And here's a place that's
willing to buy metal.
So I turned my friend and I said hey,
how would you feel about calling these
people up or just visiting them out of
the blue and saying why don't you pay us
to remove your old equipment
that's just dying in your yard.
We'll take it away.
And then we would take that
equipment to the recycle plant.
He thought this was a brilliant idea.
He was willing to
contribute his truck and
both of us would use our physical
prowess to move this heavy equipment.
And shortly after doing that, we had
quickly cleared out the territory that
we were in, farm equipment and had quite
a bit of money in our bank accounts.